[Music]
the completion of the human genome
project lays a foundation for
systematically studying the human genome
from evolutionary history to precision
medicine against diseases
with the explosive growth of biological
data there is an increasing number of
biological databases that have been
developed in aid of human related
research
in this lecture we will present a brief
overview of the major human related
biological databases
how the data is being arranged and
classified into different categories
according to their data types
and how to retrieve and analyze them as
human related databases continue to grow
not only in count
but also in volume challenges are ahead
in big data storage
processing exchange and curation
what is a database a database is a
collection of information that is
organized
so that it can be easily accessed
managed and updated
databases are composed of computer
hardware and software for data
management
the chief objective of the development
of a database is to organize data in a
set of structured records to enable easy
retrieval of information
although data retrieval is the main
purpose of all databases
biological databases often have a higher
level of requirement
known as knowledge discovery which
refers to the identification of
connections between pieces of
information that were not known when the
information was first entered
for example databases containing raw
sequence information can perform
extra computational tasks to identify
sequence homology
or conserved motifs these features
facilitate the discovery of new
biological insights from raw data
according to a report of 2014 molecular
biology database collection in the
journal nucleic acids research
there are a sum of 1005 databases that
are publicly accessible online
this does not include online services
without publication in peer-reviewed
journal
or being developed by commercial
companies
thus the actual number of online
databases could well exceed this number
considering the continuously
proliferating number of biological
databases
it becomes increasingly daunting and
time-consuming to navigate in the huge
volume of databases of interest
considering the heterogeneity in data
type
scope and curation biological databases
can be classified
into multiple categories under different
criteria
according to the scope of data coverage
biological databases can be
classified as comprehensive and
specialized databases
comprehensive databases cover different
types of data from numerous species in
typical examples are genbank
european molecular biology laboratory
embl
and dna data bank of japan ddbj
these three databases were established
as the international nucleotide sequence
database collaboration in 1988 to
collect and disseminate dna and rna
sequences
on the other hand specialized databases
contain specific types of data or data
from specific
organisms for example worm base is for
nematode biology and genomics and rice
wiki is for community curation of rice
genes
according to the level of data curation
biological databases can roughly fall
into primary and secondary or derivative
databases
primary databases contain raw data as
archival repository
such as the ncbi sequence red archive
whereas secondary or derivative
databases contain
curated information as added value such
as the ncbi refsec
as a consequence of the explosive growth
of data curation increasingly requires
collective intelligence for
collaborative data
integration and annotation therefore
biological databases can also be
classified as expert curated databases
such as refseq and community curated
databases
which are curated in a collective and
collaborative manner by a number of
researchers
such as gene wiki finally according to
the types of data managed in different
databases
biological databases can roughly fall
into the following categories
dna rna protein
expression pathway disease
nomenclature literature and ontology
despite having highly different
functions almost all biological
databases shared similar architectural
each consists of three tiers of software
at the bottom is a database management
system or dbms that manages a collection
of facts
at the top is the web browser that
transmits requests for data to the
database and renders the responses as
web pages
in the middle is a software layer that
mediates between the dvms and the web
browser to turn data requests into
database queries
and to transform the query responses
into hypertext markup language
or html in addition to the gene database
in pdb
there are many more biological databases
designed for different purposes
the table here shows some of the most
commonly used databases in
bioinformatics that might help you in
your research
you